CNN you worked there for how long 20
years 20 years so when you were hired
who was the CEO wow there were there was
a lot of turnover at the beginning it
was Walter Isaacson was the CEO who who
hired me Walter um yeah yeah
he was the editor of Time Magazine and
at that point my magazine was owned by
Time Warner which was part of a part of
part of the Time Warner company and
briefly
um he took over CNN and he hired me he
used to joke that was the only good
thing he did while he was in CNN I don't
know I hope he still feels that way oh
yeah
Walter laughed uh CNN and then and then
started writing all these terrific when
did you work at CNN what year was it
when did I start it well I was at ABC
from 96 to 2002 and then CNN 2002 to
2012. Ted Turner was still around at
that time or no well I mean Ted Turner
is still around no no but but I mean he
was not over the company no no he was he
was not how different is CNN then than
it is today
considerably different
um the um the when I started it was
still in the era of the the the line
that and this is a Ted Turner line was
the news is the star
that um it was not about the the
personalities other than Larry King who
was nine to ten the anchors were not
particularly well known not and and it
was very much like a sort of wire
service like the AP or um and
um it
and and that is a dramatic
transformation from where it was now the
the key point about 2002 is that the
internet was still in its infancy so
if you wanted news
you really had to go to to CNN
as the internet became ubiquitous
people would get the news first on their
screens than on their phones and by the
time you turned on your TV you already
knew the headlines and that's when CNN
really started to change a lot and you
were there up until 2022 I want to say
yeah so uh going back to my initial
question regarding the CEOs you were
there Jeff Zucker was there for yeah yes
and then recently Chris Licht was hired
then fired yeah I don't know if there's
a new CEO right now if they haven't
hired okay gotcha so you said that
things have changed significantly yeah
you said you know the news was the star
right we've seen recently the stars have
actually been fired Don Lemon Cuomo
right yeah Anderson Cooper's still there
wolf Blitz are still there uh you made a
little joke about the average age of the
audience is dying or actually dead yeah
same thing that's approximate yeah of
course you know give or take a few years
Grandma's watching I love you stay
strong
um you know the whole narrative about
mainstream media is that it's a dying uh
Main Legacy Media is dying and that the
average age of people is uh is dead the
other narrative is that they've lost
their credibility
um and that goes across the board uh you
know if you talk people on the left fox
has no credibility whatsoever zero why
we could even trust that the most
trusted name in news what have you and
then you go to CNN it's like anyone on
the right is like it's fake news it's
fake news we've all we've all we've all
this narrative uh speaking as someone
that's worked for CNN uh for 20 years
how can CNN regain their credibility
it's a really tough question and and
um and I think
um some some of the problems that we're
talking about are are more structural
than
um
than about any individual I mean you
know CNN makes most of its money not all
of it makes most of its money from
um Carriage fees from the cable
companies what does that mean that means
like when you if you if you get cable
new if you if you have a a cable TV at
home yeah you pay a certain amount per
month that's why I cut the cord baby
well this is the thing and and you know
let's say you pay fifty dollars a month
you know a dollar goes to CNN two
dollars goes to ESPN but
those that business is is dying now
there's a debate about how quickly it's
dying but no one really debates about
whether it's dying ESPN and so the
question is how does CNN and this is
true for see you know for for both MSNBC
and fox it's also true for ESPN which is
a bigger business than either one of
them
um how do they make the transition when
people get their news from the internet
rather than from cable
um what you know what what Zucker
recognized was that
um
when when
you know particularly at prime time
um every by the time they turned on
everybody already knew the headlines
they wanted analysis and they wanted
from people who were ideologically
simpatico
um and and so the the network I think
was what was accurate I don't think I
mean I I don't think anybody was lying
on CNN but it was certainly more
ideologically combative with Trump
um Chris lick tried to move away from
that but there isn't one of the things I
think we're learning is that you know
people go to news organizations now that
are ideologically simpatic
not to learn anything new although one
of the things that you know people never
talk about here and it's interesting it
certainly hasn't come up in this
conversation is the network news and
here I do a quick I do a quiz my wife my
wife gets sick of this I want to ask the
four of you okay we love quizzes who are
the three Network news anchors now
uh on NBC you've got Lester Holt very
good
and then who the hell watches CBS
you got uh Stephen Colbert no no but I'm
kind of kind of I honestly don't even
really know
there no those names aren't sorry did I
get two out of three rights you've got
two out of three Nora O'Donnell is the
crew yeah but but you know it 20 years
ago Dan Rather Peter Jennings and Tom
Brokaw were three of the most famous
people in the United States I mean
forget like and there's credibility well
that but a number one mattered and it
was a war it was it was a war and and
these and
and and those network shows still draw a
significant number of people every night
but they are not part of the political
conversation the way the way cable is
and
um
you know the the the the the and they
are not particularly ideological those
three shows but the question you know
that that I don't have the answer to is
sort of how the market evolves when
Court cutting continues yeah so back to
my uh yeah other question The
credibility thing so you know not all uh
Talking Heads Are are created the same
so for instance I find that Jake Tapper
has a lot of credibility I actually find
him to be a real journalist I mean some
people might disagree and then you have
some people like Don Lemon what it was
so freaking clear drama queen that he
was biased yeah who do you think is
actually the most Fair journalist these
days you know you got Tucker Carlson up
there that he's got a loyal audience
he's on Twitter now but people on the
left think he's an absolute full of
and then you've got you know Rachel
Maddow that people love her on the left
people on the right thing she's full of
who do you find to be credible
these days well I I mean I love my
colleagues at CNN I think Jake Tapp
Upper Wolf Blitzer Anderson Cooper Aaron
Burnett our terrific journalists and I
think do a great job and I was very
proud to to work to work with them hey
if you enjoyed this short Club you want
to watch the whole thing click over here
but if you want to make 2023 the
beginning of the greatest years of your
life I host a conference once year it's
called The Vault conference where 3 000
CEOs executive entrepreneurs from around
the world come together to strategize
for three and a half days this year it's
going to be at Miami Diplomat Resort and
the speakers this year is going to be
Tom Brady he'll be there I'll be
interviewing them Mike Tyson will gudara
the guy that ran 11 Madison in New York
if you run a business if you're a CEO
entrepreneur and executive this is not
an event you want to miss out on get
yourself your spouse your business
partner your running mates registered
and I look forward to seeing you there
click on the link here or see the link
in the description and I hope to spend
three and a half days with you in Miami
in August and September take care
everybody
thank you